season of the worthy will bring the
return of one of destiny twos most
anticipated and hyped PvP activities
trials of Osiris but this won't be the
only significant addition however so
here's everything you need to know as we
head into the next season the foundation
and building blocks for season if the
worthy was spread throughout season of
the dawn but the important pillars with
the Imperium foundation community event
and the seasonal exclusive activity
known as the sundial from the season of
the worthy gameplay trailers and release
calendar the stories premise involves
Anna Bray and Commander Zavala
discovering that an escaped scion flier
from the sundial has killed the engine
to the Almighty a devastating star
destroying vessel introduced during
destiny choose the red war campaign the
cabal's taken out the primary engine
like they want this thing to trek off
into space forever not
Zavala concludes that the almighty is
set on a crash course for earth and
calls on your Guardian to enlist the
assistance of Earth's last great defense
the war mind Rasputin you know why I
left infinite for us what I saw a line
has been drawn in this system light on
one side dark on the other where do you
stand
this season we'll have brand new
legendary armor and weapons available
which will be nice considering that a
lot of players have grown increasingly
vocal and agitated in wanting new pieces
of gear since there hasn't been a true
refresh in quite some time
it seems that the usual armor sets from
standard Vanguard activities and
crucible playlists aren't necessarily
going to change but there are more game
modes in this season that will have
activity exclusive armor sets for now it
remains to be seen if the armor teased
during the trailer will be what's earned
in the Seraph tower event which will be
the first new activity that will launch
one season of the worthy kicks off a new
season means a new battle pass and a lot
of the battle pass rewards remain the
same certain levels will grant you a
plethora of destination materials bright
dust rare prisms and ascendant shards
other levels will give you the seasonal
armor with progressively higher stats
cosmetic ornaments and like most battle
passes there will be both a free track
and a paid track
battle pass owners will get one complete
set of the seasonal armor right off the
bat as well as the newest exotic weapon
tommy's matchbook
I'll give Lea out of everything in
season of the worthy the return of
trials of Osiris is the biggest addition
the game mode is the pinnacle of all PvP
activities the goal is to go through
several 3v3 elimination matches in
succession without losing in order to
gain access to the lighthouse and obtain
some of the game's most coveted rewards
trials of Osiris will bring several old
stomping grounds from destiny one the
Maps Exodus blue the cauldron and
anomaly are all returning as well as the
original destiny one trials ARMA set for
all three Guardian classes trials of
Osiris will also bring a brand new title
seal for your guardian and will return
every weekend starting on Fridays it'll
be interesting to monitor how trials
fares but the hype is unmistakable for
streamers players and online spectators
without a doubt a lot of Guardians will
be eagerly anticipating the first
weekend trials goes live as they all
rally to be part of the first group of
teams to go flawless in that weekend
keep pushing there are some concerns
however especially with trials of Osiris
coming to PC some players are worried
about potential cheating while others
are curious about the manner in which
power level will factor in since trials
of Osiris is one of the rare PvP modes
where power level is enabled meaning
Guardians who are maxed out at the
season's cap will have an advantage over
lower level players although how
extensive this advantage actually is
remains to be seen
no matter how things play out destiny 2
was missing a consistent high-stakes
weekend activity like this and trials of
Osiris returning will hopefully fill
that gap in addition to the gameplay
trailer Bungie released the roadmap
calendar for season of the worthy with
highlights on the newer content that we
have yet to see this season there will
be increased difficulty as well as a
power level increase Guardians will have
all sources of powerful gear dropped
with levels up to 1000 while pinnacle
gear will go beyond that cap to reach a
max of 1010 in season of the dawn the
highest power level you could achieve
without the artifact is 970 and with the
all-new Grand Master difficulty being
introduced to the ordeal night falls the
PvE endgame appears to grow ever more
challenging players who triumph through
the challenge enough can earn endgame
rewards and a brand new seal yep it's
down like a ton of bricks the final
activity that has all of us curious is a
free event known as guardian games if
you don't have the season pass you
should still be able to take part in
this class based game that will reward
you with legendary armor for taking part
in the competition
considering that faction rallies are no
longer a thing it's nice to have some
kind of community competition based
around player choice to be honest it's
gonna be fun beating the other classes
as a warlock so there's a lot to unpack
Bungie has kept its cards pretty close
to its chest and if last season was any
indication its certain there are going
to be a few more surprises that players
can look forward to during the lulls of
the season be sure to keep an eye out
for all of our guides detailing quest
EPS strategies with trials and various
breakdown vids in the very near future
and if you want more of Destiny on your
feed let us know in the comments below
until then and best of luck to those of
you looking to go flawless we'll see you
at the lighthouse
so Joe victory